welcome to this video playing a gear
econ from France and let's see what
happens
yeah last time I played this guy we had
a very dull game when nothing much
happened ever and at the end he won rook
against rock and yeah with no points and
I didn't upload the video I didn't see
the point it was just totally useless
stuff just displaying the typical bad
sportsmanship that you see all the time
and this is why I didn't upload the
video without pointers to me okay we
have a four night's game four nights
Spanish a very complex position
sometimes it can happen that this leads
to positions that is sometimes quite
comparable to the name zone funny enough
and with this closed centre very very
interesting strategical positions I'm
trying to to really reposition my
Knights iam getting them to g6 you know
and to f6 c6 feels like a weird square
yeah not sure that this is any good but
black is always very solid
yeah h3 is not doing much at the moment
but he probably wants to cover all those
critical square so that my nights don't
do don't do any harm
okay it's not so easy to to find the
plan yeah this a pawn push means that I
cannot really move any pawns on the
Queen side hmm I wonder if I maybe
should play c5 and Bishop I don't know
c5 and a bishop to c6 try to provoke d5
but not sure that it helps me much
I can play Bishop III this is probably
not very good or this okay maybe I can I
can tickle this April a bit and now see
five maybe in c5 yeah okay
maybe try to get this close Center at
least after this I have some experience
in the resulting positions and a five is
of course what black tries to do to age
seven or eight okay I don't have time to
really figure that out f5 is what I want
to do getting getting play on their
phone okay um it's the reason not to
play it immediately Queen f7 or
something okay I should do this I don't
think there is a big drawback it was
something queen h5 i have Queen f7 for
example ya know threatening Knight f4
winning the Queen Anne's check um white
resign this is sweet revenge for this
game ye won against me with rook against
true no ports now came yeah it's a very
complicated middle game type the things
let me explain briefly how I went into
this I normally play 94 here but he has
this weird line she simply forget to
look at all the time with this and I
always have trouble against this so I
decided to play Bishop before
the classical symmetrical line which
very often leads onto exactly this and
it tends to get to this kind of position
I lost a couple of moves here with my
nightly news but it's a very very sturdy
structure anyway okay this this was okay
I think in terms of being being equal
and I know around here this five idea it
looks it looks okay to me I thought he
just he would just take then we play
play this position with about equal
chances I would say I mean I G form
something like this coming I have this
play on their phone it's very much
comparable to to the Huebner variation
in the new mezzo with a doubled C pawn
and f5 being the pawn pawn break yeah
this is just just not good yeah Queen f7
is threatening exactly night at Freud
this means he needs to move the Queen
again maybe back somewhere yeah I know I
even have the additional idea to play f4
as this is check again not on here this
the threat is quite quite a problem h4
387 it's very very good for black hmm
young this was already quite nice though
okay okay this is the check very very
helpful nevertheless okay thanks for
watching